[Music]
what's up guys I'm Kip EHD here so I've
been using the iPhone 11 Pro for about
six seven months now maybe a little
longer than that
doesn't sound like that long but for
this weird world I live in where I'm
switching between smart phones all the
time testing all these different ones
that's kind of a long time actually for
me to be using one phone one plus eight
pro in the other pocket for those of you
who know about the whole dual smartphone
situation so I figured you know what
let's do a longer term review this is
something I've seen a lot more actually
on YouTube and I really like it's um I'm
jumping in but the original review is
usually shot after one to two weeks of
using the phone and there's only so much
you can pick up in that time and
inevitably after that you not try to
tweet new things that I find but there
are new findings and new things that you
learn about a phone that you want to
share she follow me on Twitter if you
want to see those things when I do share
them but that's what this is about
so why not take a second look at one of
the phones that seems to come up all the
time months after it comes out this is
the iPhone 11 Pro revisited plus a look
forward at I phone 12 okay so one of the
things you can get a pretty good idea of
when the phone first comes out is build
quality not just how it feels in the
hand but like really how well it's
actually built and iPhones have a pretty
good track record at least as of late
you know if lasting a long time but
they're also glass and glass is glass
and I've said it before but I'll say it
again until it's no longer true I don't
use a case on my phone never really have
so this phone just travels around just
like this
so this iPhone has been in pockets in
gym bags with cleats in backpacks you
know in car cupholders it gets tossed
around a lot and put in a lot of
different places now the stainless steel
on the sides has held up great looks
almost exactly like it did the day I got
the phone which you might expect and the
matte finish on the back has done a good
job of hiding some of those micro
scratches a lot better than a glossy
your phone would but the front glass not
so much some phones get this worse than
others and from my experience iPhones
tend to get these micro scratches more
ease
we but you can see on my iPhone a lot of
visible scratches all over the display
not so bad that it would you know
actually interrupt the viewing
experience like a crack but they add up
as his phone gets used more and more now
I'm gonna say a lot of these are because
I tend to put my phone facedown on my
desk and on counters and other places
around me and we know there's plenty of
dust and random grit that can just
happen to get under there and cut the
glass of the phone but it just seems
like it's worse on the iPhone than other
phones I've used so I'm gonna try to get
out of the laying the phone down face
down have it internal specs have held up
pretty much perfectly and this is what
I'm talking about in the initial review
when I say it's got tons of performance
headroom goes out the box of course
every phone feels great and the iPhone
is one of the fastest feeling phones you
know one to six months later but that's
a sort of a trajectory for the two years
three years four years later when it's
still one of the fastest feeling two
three four year old phones that's thanks
to the 813 Bionic and four gigs of RAM
which don't look like huge specs on
paper but this phone is on pace to be
doing just fine in four years okay pop
quiz what's rule number one of buying a
new piece of tech never buy a piece of
tech like this based on the promise of
future software updates to come never do
that just buy it for what it is today
and if it happens to get better over the
years then a sabonis that I think
especially applies to iPhones because
they never really add any crazy features
like the way you know Android used to be
when they would just change everything
with a new software update but it's
mostly been minor tweaks and bug fixes
as definitely more stable now I was 13
when it first launched had a good amount
of bugs and they've been ironing those
out I had this weird bug with Gmail
attachments but that's now fixed Oh than
that not too wild in a way it's kind of
boring actually if you're hoping for
something transformative and new in the
software that's not really what I get my
hopes up for on an iPhone now the
announcements on stage and the way they
talk so smoothly about how everything's
so magical they might fool you a little
bit like remember remember the U one
chip in this phone remember that about
you could you could point your iPhone at
another airdrop device and it would just
show up on the top of the list
that hasn't really ever materialized so
when another big one was a deep fusion
remember deep fusion there's a whole
thing on stage about how a software
update coming later to this new iPhone
would bring deep fusion for improved
detail and less noise and better
sharpness in medium lighting now this
wasn't low light that would be night
mode and my modes pretty great on this
phone but it's not that and it wasn't
high light either it wasn't normal
daytime photos HDR and all that takes
care of it great but this was for medium
light well the iPhone definitely got
this software update and it definitely
has deep fusion now and I definitely
can't tell the difference and it doesn't
even really tell you which photos were
taken with deep fusion on and which ones
are just regular photos so yeah I guess
the point here is to say at the end of
the day it's just good old familiar iOS
running on the iPhone just like we all
expected there are so many future's here
and there but again not too many
surprises here and yes the cameras are
still really good I've been taking great
photos all the time in the months since
this phone came out and also also pretty
much every video you've seen on my
socials you know Twitter or Instagram
and every time I go live on Instagram
they are with almost no exceptions all
from the iPhone iOS 13.2 they finally
listened and put video resolution and
frame rate controls in the camera app
they're a little hard to press but you
can go from 30 to 60 to 24 and 4k to HD
final okay a couple of smaller things
battery life has stayed really good I
switched actually to the smaller iPhone
11 Pro I had the 11 Pro max for almost
my entire use but I guess when I
reviewed the iPhone se it kind of got me
missing smaller iPhones for a while so
for the first time in a long time I'm
not using the absolute biggest available
version of a phone I'm using the smaller
iPhone 11 Pro now and I was wrong about
3d touch I miss 3d touch 3d touch was
one of those things that you know it was
the pressure sensitivity of underneath
the screen Apple no longer makes any
devices that's
or 3d touch anymore they've gone back to
just haptic touch which is just
basically a long press and it's nowhere
near as good 3d touch while it wasn't
necessarily taken advantage of by every
single developer it was actually a
really well done and uniquely iPhone
feature it set them apart where haptic
touch is basically just that long press
and it's much slower than the pressure
sensitivity was so I'm not sure I
wouldn't trade some extra thickness to
get 3d touch back and I don't think I'm
alone there and then face ID
we're all super used to what face ID is
by now but it was supposed to get
improvements and be better with this new
iPhone it's still really good but I
think it would feel magical it would
feel amazing if they could do just a
couple little things namely shrinking
the notch and making it work from more
angles like from this this sideways
angle doesn't work when it's this far
off and when it's sideways and upside
down and other angles it's not quite as
good so actually it doesn't work at all
when it's upside down so face ID could
be more magical Tim if you're listening
but actually Tim I hope you're not
listening because let's use that as a
way to segue into looking forward a bit
at the iPhone 12 when you think about it
this phone can look a little bit dated
can feel a bit dated it's got those
rounded corners it's got the biggest
notch in any phone it's still got the
proprietary port at the bottom still got
a 60 Hertz screen it is one of the
fastest feeling phones with a 60 Hertz
screen thanks to the hundred twenty
Hertz touch refresh rate but it is still
60 Hertz and of course no 5g now iPhone
12 rumors floating around right now
point to the boxier shape similar to the
iPad pro super looking forward to that
5g should be added as well and adding
that lidar scanner from the iPad pro a
classic case of the customer paying for
a feature they may not ever use just
because it comes built into the phone
but now there's a whole new lineup of
iPhones planned at various price points
which are really interesting to me all
of which should have 5g so I'm curious
which one of these do you think you
would get look today iPhone 11 Pro as a
flagship it's kind of in this weird
place because Apple never updates their
prices this phone launched at $1000
upgraded for 1100
and it still costs $1,100 and till the
day the next phone comes out in
September or October it will still cost
1100 bucks this phone was a pretty good
buy when it came out but if you can wait
if you waited this long and you haven't
bought a new iPhone yet if you can keep
waiting to the iPhone 12 I think that's
the move I think that's the one to wait
for that's the one I'm excited about
that's the one I can't wait to upgrade
to with that new shape but until then
this has been a pretty damn good phone
for the months that's been out till then
thanks for watching catch you guys in
the next one peace